well i have the honor of talking with
nadia murad nobel peace prize laureate
and founder of nadia's initiative which
was launched after the violent
persecution of the yazidi people in iraq
at the hands of isis some eight years
ago tragically this also included your
own kidnapping and persecution and
suffering at the hands of isis
now you were awarded the nobel peace
prize for your work to fight against the
use of sexual violence as a tactic of
war used against women and children in
2018
now we're hearing horrible reports of
russian soldiers usually using sexual
violence against women and children in
ukraine for yourself when you hear this
kind of news what are your thoughts what
are your feelings
you know
it is heartbreaking uh for me as a
survivor of sexual violence and a
genocide to see that
what happened to me in my community in
2014 is happening right now to
thousands of people in ukraine
i have been watching the news very
closely the the reports of sexual
violence and
you know and we know that whenever a
conflict
can't break out we see that the sexual
violence follows and and we are seeing
that in ukraine right now but
i am i'm glad that the international
community is uh
seems more united more than ever to
address the the use of sexual violence
at a very you know an early
you know quickly because in in the past
and and from my experience in when isis
what isis did to us
uh it was sexual violence was not in the
international community's agenda when
they you know talk about war and
conflict
but this time we're seeing more leaders
more politicians more
even the media are talking about it and
reporting and listening to survivors in
ukraine
well we know that last month you
publicly unveiled
murad's code which was a supposed to be
an international guideline
for
helping i guess leadership country
leadership
learn to
support
survivors of sexual assault and help
them seek justice which in some ways
couldn't be better timing considering
what is going on right now in ukraine
why did you feel it was necessary to
develop this code and what do you hope
to accomplish through it
you know i've been working with the uk
government recently and we we were able
to launch the morale code last month in
in
at the united nations
uh you know survivors of
i'm telling you from a personal
experience in in idp camps when
there were thousands of yezidi survivors
telling their stories and and
testimonies but they were not
you know they they were not
told that how their stories and their
testimonies their photos will be used or
will not you know that the
the
likely outcomes of of their testimonies
uh there are you know
the hope of like doing this code is that
to make sure that journalists
investigators and anyone who is engaging
working with survivors they will do it
in a supportive and respectful way
because survivors they are ready to tell
us their stories they are the one that
went through everything and we need
their uh testimonies as an uh evidence
to
use against the abuser the perpetrators
to hold them accountable so it is so
important to make sure that they are
safe and they they have all the support
that they need and we already we have
translated to
the ukraine and ukrainian language and
we shared with the government and with
the survivors so that everyone can can
follow that
the guidelines
well talking about justice and
accountability we know that recently a
german court convicted a member of isis
for genocide
what does that mean for you and for your
work knowing that that conviction came
through
you know
for me for my work and for every
survivors you know everyone
every survivor deserves uh their day in
court and the the what what that isis
member did to the uh to the community
and to this that specific
child and the women it was something
public and
uh
you know the german government
they they showed that
there is no impunity from such crimes
and there is no culture of impunity from
you know
committing genocide and sexual violence
and we're working to make other european
countries to use that you know germans
example and follow their example to
hold more perpetrators accountable this
is just one case we have thousands of
testimonies and evidence documents from
the united and from survivors so we are
hoping that we can see more cases like
this because there is there is no
healing without justice
especially for survivors yeah
and we find ourselves here at the world
economic forum this week where world
leaders will be discussing of course the
war in ukraine the pandemic rising
consumer prices where do you see
your initiative fitting in what are your
expectations for davos this week
you know i'm here uh to make sure that
the topic of conflict-related sexual
violence is something within their
agenda uh there are leaders here
politicians ngos uh
and and we are hoping that we can
address this thing we can see it as a
not just as a side effect of of conflict
sexual violence is being used as a
weapon of war throughout the history and
uh we are hoping that hunadies
initiative the global survivors fund
that i co-founded with my uh friend dr
dennis mccoy
to
make sure that we support survivors we
don't forget them because there are so
many things going on in the world and
the in the world leaders and and the
media move on very fast but
for survivors it's not that easy to just
move on and and it is so important to
support them through operations through
justice accountability and to listen to
them and to make sure that
we our voice is is hurt here too by
leaders and and
everyone here
well there's obviously a lot of work
involved being an activist against
sexual violence as you are what
in your mind is one of the biggest
hurdles or frustrations that you face
you know in in our case in yezidi's case
in in our work in sinjar it there are so
many challenges there are some political
challenges for example right now in
sinjar as you said at the beginning it's
been eight years since isis committed a
genocide against the yezidis and we we
still have thousands of people in
displacement camps only two hours away
from their homeland the international
community failed to protect us in 2014
but they also have failed to help people
to go back to their homeland and help
them to have access to
proper education health care and and and
you know by just basic services there
are thousands of women and girls who are
in displacement
camps and they don't have basic privacy
there are there's child marriage there
is suicide and there are so many
challenges but the biggest one is that
you know we are it's so hard to convince
the governments ngos to focus on
sustainable solutions after that the
conflict is end and i think we cannot
help people to fully recover from the
from the trauma if we don't focus on
sustainable solutions in their own
homeland and make sure that they have a
dignified life after what they've been
through
how has the pandemic affected your work
you know like everyone's else it was not
easy for for our work
our work is not like a business to do it
through you know zoom and other uh
online um meetings it was hard to
explain it i this work needs to you know
go to people go to students leaders ngos
and talk to them for hours to to tell
them about what is what is happening to
tell them about the ongoing needs for
for survivors to to be able to heal and
recover
uh it
it was not easy for us and that is why
right now we are trying to go to
everywhere and and and do what we can to
help
survivors in iraq in ukraine in in
ethiopia and yemen in other places
but
it it it was not easy and i'm i'm trying
my best to to make sure that
uh
that we still have the the
the media's and the world leaders
attention on on the topic of conflict
related sexual violence and the
aftermath of genocide and how we can
help communities to thrive again and
through our work yeah
nadia murad thank you so much and best
of luck with your work thank you so much